new this morning do you know the signs
of a stroke do you know what to do if
you're having one well unfortunately
every 40 seconds if you can believe that
every 40 seconds someone in the U.S has
a stroke for survived stroke week we
want to give you the tools to protect
yourself Candace Charles joining us live
with what you need to know Candace good
morning good morning to good morning
folks yes it is stroke awareness month
this week it should survived stroke week
it's part of the get ahead of stroke
campaign brought to you guys by the
members of the Society of
neo-interventional surgery you know a
lot of people remember the burnt toast
smell of the symptom it's a phantom
symptom apparently American aad CPR says
that it's something that maybe you can
catch on to if you're going to be having
a stroke something you should also
remember though is be fast it's an
acronym that can save your life take a
look at your screen here the b stands
for loss of balance e for your eyes
meaning blurry or loss of vision f for
face drooping a arm weakness s for
speech difficulty and most importantly
folks a t for time now neuro
instrumentalists say it's one of the
most important ones because if you're
experiencing any of these symptoms you
need to act quickly and get the right
care it can mean the difference between
walking and being permanently paralyzed
we really want to try to get people to
go to the right center there are certain
centers that are able to perform clot
busting injections or even procedures
where we can go up into someone's brain
and pull the clot out
and stroke unfortunately is impacting
and younger people more than it used to
which is why they get ahead of stroke
campaign really is so important coming
up I'll share what the American Heart
Association says about the increased
prevalence of stroke in younger people
and the tips for preventing it we'll
share details on our website newsnow.com
for now live in The Newsroom I'm Candice
Charles 8 News Now